-You did a really nice piece
yesterday about the fact tha
post-impeachment Donald Trump --
many Republicans when they voted
to not impeach said that
"We do feel like this will b
a teachable moment for him."
-"He's learned his lesson.
-"He will learn his lesson
He's been cowed by this."
-He definitely learned a lesson.
-What was the lesson?
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, I think the lesson is that
he -- I mean, the lesson I think
that he has learned is, "I nee
to get all the bad people
out of my administration,
anybody who is
not disloyal to me."
-Right, not bad as in they d
bad things, but bad in tha
"They will tell other people
when I do bad things."
-Yes.
Whistleblowers potentially
But also anybody "who woul
testify against me,"
or anybody who would
theoretically not be 100% loyal.
And so he has done
all these things, you know
not just escorting people like
Lieutenant Colonel Vindman
and his twin brother,
who had nothing to do with it,
escorting them off
the White House grounds
and other impeachment witness.
But there was a guy who was th
top policy guy at the Pentagon
who privately had been saying,
"No, you need to release
the money to Ukraine.
The money was --"
-Yeah.
-He didn't do anything wrong
He didn't even make it public.
But he got fired.
I mean, so anybody that gets i
the way of what he wants to do
even if what he wants
to do is against the law,
he is now having them
leave the administration.
And he's trying to help people
who have been loyal, like
Roger Stone is a good example.
He went after the prosecutors.
He went after the judge.
He went after the jury forewoman
in the Roger Stone prosecution
He has this perception
that prosecutors are bad.
-Yeah.
-And bad guys are good.
-You know what I'm starting to
think? He might be a bad guy
[ Laughter ]
I think he might just be
a bad guy with bad judgment.
-I think there are some judgment
questions that could be asked.
-I want to ask this.
Before your days
as a journalist,
you started on the Internet.
You had a job at
a very highly revered website.
-It was revered.
-Was it revered at the time?
-It was.
-I don't remember it well.
But it was -- It was suck.com.
-Yeah.
And when you say it like that,
you make it sound dirty.
[ Laughter ]
But suck.com was this -- was -
-Wait, how would you say it?
You worked at suck.com.
[ Laughter ]
[ English accent ] Joining u
now, Jake Tapper from suck.com
[ Laughter ]
-It was this very guerilla
website started by
some of the editors
of Wired Digital.
-[ Normal voice ] Okay.
-And people wrote these column
that were scathing commentarie
on things going on
in the Internet.
And it was -- A lot of great
people got their starts there.
Ana Marie Cox and Joey Anuff
and a bunch of others.
And Tim Carvell I think
wrote for them.
-Oh, wow.
-So in any case, there wer
a lot of people who wrote there.
Yes. And we all had --
you had pseudonyms.
So you didn't write
under your name.
The website's gone, by the way
It's vanished.
You can't get it anymore.
But it was suck for like
"this sucks,"
not for whatever you thought
[ Laughter ]
-What do you think
I thought it was?
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
It seemed like you were judging.
[ Applause ]
-You wrote for the vacuum review
site, suck.com.
[ Laughter ]
-Suck.com was
part of Wired Digital. Yeah.
-Well, hey, it's always
so wonderful to have you here.
You've got to come back soon
-Thank you.
-Jake Tapper, everybody.